I kept saying during the lockdowns that
you were destroying 8 to 15 year olds
you're destroying them this is the age
in which the peer relationship is so
important and you're not allowing them
that you're handing them iPads and where
they're getting sexting and watching
porn anywhere they're not getting any
education and you're telling them they
can't contact their peers and if they do
they're going to kill their
family and in the meantime shelter in
place remember Garcetti kept saying
every night shelter in Place shelter in
place that is a phrase s reserved for an
incoming nuclear weapon I I I kid that's
what that is or an active
shooter before Co H right when it was
hitting I did an interview with a guy
named Larry brilliant he's the world's
leading expert on small poox and he said
you don't you don't need to do anything
when when epidemics hit people naturally
isolate they they watch out for
themselves and they isolate socially
that's just a natural phenomenon and it
is inevitable so the idea of having all
this centralization and Authority on
high is the problem right now it is it
is making things worse what do you make
of the the psychological component now
for young people because we're seeing
rates of anxiety that are through the
roofed now drug use all the I mean I
think you can actually connect this to
the gender confusion too like just
everything is kind of up in the air at
this point for these people just I kept
saying during the lockdowns that you
were destroying 8 to 15 year olds you're
destroying them th this is the age in
which the peer relationship is so
important and you're not allowing them
that you're handing them iPads and where
they're getting sexting and watching
porn anyway they're not getting get any
education and you're telling them they
can't contact their peers and if they do
they're going to kill their
family and in the meantime shelter in
place remember Garcetti kept saying
every night shelter in Place shelter in
place that is a phrase
s reserved for an incoming nuclear
weapon I I I kid that's what that is or
an active shooter if proud to say you
were at illegal parties at my house Dr
Drew I don't think it's going to cost
you your license at this point you're
right those were illegal was was was the
French underground back in those days
right we were like this this like group
trying to put information out trying to
continue to share ideas and uh if you're
9 years old and you're telling them that
that shelter in place and you're going
to kill your family and no peer contact
of course there's going to be depression
anxiety and developmental delays and
cognitive issues it's just inevitable
and on top of that there the the economy
to the young people that I've spoken to
looks bleak not only does the economy
look ble the the usual sorts of
motivations for engagement they can't
get inspired by anything there are a lot
of like who cares why do I everything
sucks we suck America sucks you Boomers
suck why do I want to dedicate my time
and live life to some Pursuit what what
am I going to do with it it's really sad
it's really it makes me crazy that's why
I said when I was going around walking
around Coconut Grove and seeing a lot of
young people out there socializing like
please yes more this so what what do you
do I mean from a therapist perspective
what would you do if you're you're
talking to now a group of 12y olds who
okay they were nine when this was
happening they're anxiety ridden they're
confused about a bunch of stuff like
what what do you actually do like
anything you try to you know manage the
conditions whatever comes along you try
to get them to engage in reality on
reality's
terms and then make a difference how do
you because you know most people get
through crises of any type or even
mental illness of any type for that
matter with service of some type there's
always that some sort of Engagement as
part of it and you've got to get them
there and my I I would not be good with
that population because I would say
aren't you angry aren't you pissed
aren't you Furious you're I'm not
supposed to you don't do that in therapy
you don't give them your stuff but I
hope they get to a place where they are
Furious livid and want to make a
difference and get things back on track
where people can be inspired there's
also a spiritual malady that's been
going on in this country for quite some
time and that has become acute I I don't
know exactly what that looks like to
solve it but we we've got to do
something on that front where do you
think the prescription drug uh I would
say pandemic falls into that maybe
that's not your the over
prescribing
yeah I saw something uh I think a week
ago we showed it on the show that about
10% of American adults are on something
48hd you know either adderal or one of
these things and to me it seems like
even if a huge percentage of those
people it's necessary in some respect in
helping them yes that a a society that
10% of its people are drugged one way or
another there's something much bigger
going on here I I think that's true like
there is something bigger going on and
in terms of the medication think we are
this is what always happens in mental
health we are are at once
overprescribing and underprescribing
people I again look at the streets yeah
people who need medication aren't
getting it and if they don't want to
take it you're supposed to just go okay
when they die because they don't and
then there are people that come in with
a little um ordinary misery when when uh
Sigman Freud first this I don't know if
this apocryphal story or not but Sig for
apparently when he hit the hit the
shores in New York reporters came up and
said Dr Freud what do you hope to
achieve here in America and he said well
I hope to understand the difference
between real mental illness and ordinary
misery and we have we have lost track of
for book ordinary misery it's a good you
can have it no it's fine you can have it
you can have it but but we need ordinary
misery is good for us it's how we create
resiliency and how we solve problems and
we are we are intolerant of ordinary
misery and at the same time we've lost
track of what it even means to be happy
and happiness has become this what's
called I think we've talked about this
before UD dionic happy I'm Excuse me
hedonic happiness which is just woohoo
which is great I love that kind of
happiness but it it doesn't last and
it's always a an appetite of drive to
more more more UD demonic happiness
which is an active engagement in a
meaningful nourishing life people don't
even understand what that is anymore so
it's basically sort of the difference
between a sense of purpose which would
be the latter and just like I'm having a
great time today because I'm going to
the amusement park a a good life and a
party and I when I first started
thinking about this different I thought
oh yeah my heroin addicts are super
happy first h of the day is that are
they happy is that happiness but they're
happy in that moment but it's it's not
happiness happiness and you know I sort
of lately I've been people have been
resonating with this when I say
look Jesus Christ lived a purposeful
good life wasn't always always happy if
he had focused on hedonic tone on that
kind of Happiness things would have
turned out quite differently and often a
good life is a life of sacrifice a life
of Engagement a life of of work of doing
hard work so how do you all right we
talked about how you can get people off
some of the drugs let's say how do you
get people off all of the wrong ideas
now when you also have a generation that
is confused about sexuality they're
confused about the founding of the
nation just that that freedom is bad and
good You Up Is Down two plus two is five
all those things that's a different type
of addiction different problem uh I
think reality has a way of asserting
itself I think reality I'm I'm watching
you know sort of my children's peer age
kind of wake up in the real world and
kind of go oh well maybe that isn't so
maybe that wasn't so true or maybe I was
a little deep in it ideology whenever
ideology takes hold humans suffer they
just
do uh I mean just look at history so we
need to really Hammer I mean there's so
much engag engagement in social media
you can talk about freem you Freedom you
can bring ideas out that they haven't
heard before you can constantly push
historical sort of tidbits out so people
come to understand what what this
country is founded on and what the other
histories of other countries have been
that we can learn from that they seem
totally disconnected from and so it's
it's um I just think persistence I think
keeping it going and allowing reality to
assert itself and then I'm hoping a real
anger will emerge in Young people where
they go hey I was I was taught some
and they I believed it and now
they didn't serve me well and I'm angry
about it it's funny the therapist who
wants people to be angry yeah yeah I'm
I'm an internist you got remember I'm an
internist by training so I go back to my
medical Roots even though I worked in a
psychiatric hospital for 35 years but
yes I want people to be furious if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell